hey et my name is greg go vanessi and I
played Chuck Stewart on when Hoke calls
and here we are in the beautiful town of
Brookfield and I'm gonna give you tour
[Music]
here we are at the Royal Brook fuel
hotel and let's have a look inside here
we are in the hotel and this is just one
example of the beautiful craftsmanship
of this crew they've built this entire
town on this little sliver of land and
it's it's just great like the attention
to detail like these are all oh that
works that's cool
this actually is a functioning record
player which was played in one of my
favorite scenes in the big soiree at the
top of episode 1 this is also really
1910 that let's hear what do we got we
have Laura moon 508 Spruce Street Eagle
Point there's no date on it look at this
even like that's how they would write in
the 1960s like that's how they would
write like even down to the letters look
at that that's amazing and these are all
the keys to the six rooms of the
Brookfield hotel and I'll let you in on
a little secret this one number four
this is the key to chalk art was that
got the cheesiest day that humor we've
been using the term humor to loosely and
one of my favorite focal points of this
this hotel are actually the staircase
actually been up there you should go
check that out never done that pork
and it's kind of all right are you ready
dinner man one take this for yourself
are these full roll
yeah I'm do I'm giving it to you tour
[Music]
these are our dream these are chaps and
we get to wear these oh man I love these
I'd love the chaps it's like when I put
the chaps on like I'm a real cowboy so
do you just look like a cowboy or are
you the real thing yeah can you do me up
man it's quite an extensive process to
put these things on actually it takes
like it could 5 minutes we do can we do
can we do a little like cowboy see I
need I need like a little this is the
after dark version of what ho called see
how fast my drawers I want to take them
across the street if you can
can I bring the chaps oh yeah
all right so this is my office we we've
shot a few scenes here actually and we
switch the room around as needed this is
where we sit in between scenes you know
joseline
shows us pictures of Rupert her dog we
kind of just chat here while we're
waiting go over lines things like that a
little trick of the trade there's a
light in here this is an actual fire
we've already had one prisoner and I
wait to see I'll wait for you to see who
it is but this is where I I threw him in
jail throwing someone in jail is is
pretty fun you know when you go when you
catch the bad guy and you really win the
day
so what's gonna happen to me stand trial
and Clearwater
I'll back we have well we we have
nothing
maybe subsequent seasons will build that
out a little bit maybe I'll have a place
to live
apartment or something Lisa gonna do for
the town hero not a hero it's exactly
what a hero would say this is my desk
over here usually it's pulled out a
little further in the desk chairs around
here this is where I hold court this is
a little drawer back here where I
usually keep my phone so take you along
the boardwalk here in episode one
there's a great scene where my horse is
actually up here it's a it's the first
time I meet Lilian so hopefully
resonates with people it did with me if
you'll excuse me
all right so this is Joe Moody's store
it's great got some onions here anybody
want some no I had my first scene with
Wendy Crewson right over here I was
grooming my horse I was just learning
how to do that that day so that was that
was pretty fun there's always someone
you met in trouble I think if the
Mounties job is never done comes with
the uniform okay so this is a pretty
cool it's a pretty cool area we're gonna
need the light here cuz it's probably
gonna be pretty dark so this is a
Mountie office in Clearwater this is the
regional headquarters these notes they
actually write real stuff on those notes
I'm not a huge fan of kind of looking at
nothing and the detail is really nice
from the props team they're doing a
great job we've got some some old-time
you wanted ads I wanted posters just on
the lookout for these people within
these posters you see Jane Elizabeth
Smith that's not an inside joke or
anything that's just the name they made
after this but I know that sometimes in
in films and in TV they they plant real
names you know you'll see a David
Anselmo or a bratty wall sure there's
someone kind of playing a joke but I
think that those come maybe later in the
season or in subsequent seasons and
people get grounded and sure that
they're doing the right thing first
before they do the wrong thing so if you
take a look out this one though you have
the orphanage where I think they're
shooting right now soul will be quiet
that is a it's a house that they built
and if you were to add plumbing
electricity it would be you could live
there you wouldn't want to do that now
cuz we're in North Bay and you would
freeze to death in the winter for sure
so over here another office typewriter
details details details and then we'll
come into this last room that I want to
show you because it's a it's a pretty
exciting spot this room here is what we
call the no physical contact room this
is where I came to talk to a prison the
prisoner was sitting over there on on
the other side of bars in one take I
went like this I went like this and of
course they sound like wood so I'm
really interested to see what it will
sound effect on their form
I'm guessing we're gonna we're gonna
have to use this room quite a bit mm-hmm
talk to different business but it's
really fun well ET thanks so much for
coming to visit us here at when hope
calls unfortunately I have to go do some
Mountie stuff right now I gotta find my
horse
his name's Apollo and he is a pain in
[Music]